okay hi everyone we are continuing a
design review for our question function
framework
um
right
so
names of question okay we're talking
about question interface
all right
help me out
with where we should start here
are you telling page
okay
and um
that line of code you could open up as
well those are just some samples for
what the individual doc pages for the
question interface types might look like
okay
all right so
explain to me how i run this i mean so
in other words if i say
i'm trying to make a quiz
and where does this exactly fit in is
that what i'm about to see in this thing
here
um no well no so far it only fits in
inside of a question object these aren't
don't really do anything stand alone
okay
do they just sit there on
i mean they just they just sit they just
sit there and okay that's not
necessarily an evaluated form right
um
okay so let's so what should i look at
here um so this is like the content of
the documentation we need a new doc type
page that brian van verdler is going to
set up
and this is sort of the
sketch of the content that's going to
fill those pages
okay but just show me a basic example
here is this the basic example that's a
basic example right
okay so
remind me what the difference is between
a question object and a question
interface
uh the question object has assessment in
it
can't assess and what makes it a
question interface as opposed to just a
general interface right so that was the
question that you posed last time and we
took
that to
some
of interested people to see if they
thought we should generalize this
to make something like a multiple choice
interface object that lives outside the
question world
and they said that then really makes
sense and that we should just make it
live in the quest explain why
i mean what does this question interface
do this question interface
basically makes
it defines
an interface which could to me i don't
understand why it can't be in a
manipulate for example
well what lou said is that if there's if
there's a control type that's missing
that we should add the control type
basically is lou here could if not can
we find that no he's not but i could
find him
okay um
okay so
i don't understand i mean i i just don't
get
the main added benefits to this over the
underlying controller
are
closely tied to the fact that it is a
question object with assessment okay why
why explain why
one of the main things is like marking
up correct and incorrect answers adding
up that's in the question interface is
that right
yes yes so that that will be part of the
the payload here of the question
interface but you're not like that's
here
we're not showing that in these simple
examples and it's not implemented in
most cases yet
okay
okay so here
i see so this would automatically
surface the question interface given the
assessment function
exactly
right everything you need to know is
inferred from the assessment function
you could give the things explicitly and
overwrite it but you don't need well
okay fair enough i'm i'm i'm warming to
the idea that this is a separate kind of
thing
although i think it'll be frustrating to
people if there's something which you
can get
you know it's like the
people using data set just because it
does formatting type thing right
right it's like
that's a possibility here and then the
only problem is that the term question
might be slightly a misnomer i know i
know so that's my point that's my point
right
there
but why is it okay but you could
question just a controller right for
most of these things you could get the
same thing with just a controller
well except the synthetic different
right
syntax is completely detected
right which is not good
so
i mean in this case
what does this do here does this this
has no assessment right so it doesn't
have a submit button
so what is this this is a disembodied
interface
right you could use this like a survey
right but it you know it's
can you use a survey i mean what about
okay so
in a form
i see in a form notebook
you could have something just like this
is that correct that's right in the in
the q a formula or potentially even in
this okay which you could then harvest
correct and then yes and then it would
be harvested with the data for the form
notebook yes how what how is that and
how does that relate to the dynamic
mechanism
current interfaces well
i'm not sure what you're referring to
well i mean when you do that
let me answer the first half of your
question before you dive into the second
half okay all right so in a standard
form notebook if you put in a question
object it would that you know the user's
value that they're sitting there would
show up in
the data that you do whatever to add to
a data bin send an email whatever in a q
a form notebook
it would be uh it would go through the
assessment routine which would kind of
has built in
storage and yeah it wouldn't actually be
marked right or wrong but sort of the
it would use one the standard storing
mechanisms okay
lou
hello
yes hi there okay
so
my question is
right now
with interfaces
we are using the whole dynamic mechanism
we take i mean what will be the analog
of this
as a existing interface mechanism
is this radio button
what is this
well
what we're looking at right now is a
radio button bar
it's a select one from many control and
we have lots of select one from many
controls we have everything
yeah okay so how would i actually get
this exact thing with the radio button
bar
you would the first argument is a
dynamic reference to the variable
storing the value and then the second
argument is the set of choices
so
list string red comma string yeah
[Music]
okay
so
and what if i want to say pick a color
well then we have things like column and
panel and things let you build up
you know okay so let's say panel column
you know
okay
so
what's happening here
is
if i say dynamic of arg
here i get that that's my means of
communication here
in this case my means of communication
is there isn't a means of now in this
case is that is there a one-argument
form
of radio button bar that doesn't have a
dynamic variable
there is for slider right
there is a zero argument form for slider
yes
and i guess there's a one-argument form
as well where you can give a
real
um but no radio button bar
requires attaching to a dynamic variable
slider dynamic of x
would be it will be ambiguous if there
was a one argument form
it's not ambiguous because it has head
dynamic which is i see distinguishable
okay okay
okay so
our mechanism right now is
and you know one of the things that's
interesting you know we invented
dynamics long before
all of these you know react like
interfaces existed but i think they work
in a somewhat similar way is that a true
statement
uh comment on that
i'm not sure what you mean by react
style interfaces well like the react
javascript framework
it has a way of
dealing with
you know dynamic content that i think is
in the end
this reactive i don't know i i haven't
followed our dynamic mechanism is based
entirely on symbol values
i i know how our dynamic mechanism works
i don't think i know how it works i'm
asking i'm asking in the 20 years since
we 25 years since we invented it
right or whatever it is how long is it
now
it's um
uh it was version six right
so it's about nearly 20 years since we
invented this
there are different ideas in the world
about interfaces
which include ones which i think are
somewhat similar although maybe not as
fancy as the ideas that we have about
this but what we're basically bringing
in here is a this dynamic mechanism
isn't what we're using here right so for
a form notebook we have a different
concept instead of storing state
in dynamic variables
which are kind of hidden state relative
to the controls what we're doing is the
controls are the story
and we're then harvesting the control
values right which is similar
to the setting mechanism that we have
right right
have we hooked that up to work at all
silvia or shorter no use there's not
setting for question objects
okay okay but so so
just so i understand
if i say i don't even know how i how do
i use this again i can say
um
this would be okay so here i would say
um
i could do that
and now i can move this around and then
i can get a value so that is a very
that's a very similar concept
so setting
is the pull the value from the outside
version for our dynamic controls now how
would i do that for a radio button bar
like since i don't want a dynamic
variable there
lou
um well you can have a non dyna radio
button bar that's based on a non-dynamic
variable
so you say red as the first argument
or you know why do i have to do that i
mean why do i have to do that and and so
that that's the documented syntax
okay
all right but i mean but then the analog
here
is what is the analog here when i first
bring this up
okay
nothing is selected
which means that actually isn't
okay so that's a different form of radio
button bar that has nothing selected so
to speak
the
um
right if you copy that output nine into
setting it works
i mean
definitely
as far as an initial value radio button
bar is no different from slider you
can't have a slider without a value you
can't have a radio button bar without a
value a pop-up menu
without a value
um
okay
well so okay so by the way why did that
produce quotes when i just command shift
whatever
because input style has show string
characters set to true
so if i end paneled it would still be
like that or not i think panel turns
that off if not one there's an option
for turning it off
i think panel that's that option though
um
magnificent
okay
so this is now the metaphor this is
purely setting go through the panel
setting probably doesn't go through the
panel
oh
interesting
oh sorry i was muted yes setting is
rodentifies but it doesn't remove
non-dynamics
that's clever actually i like it
okay
okay so so let me just understand that
so what you're proposing here
is something which
is
you know you're proposing a new world of
controls basically
a layer on top of controls
well it's but it's a different design
right but you could imagine in one of
the
things in the association in question
your face being controlled just like in
form object where you could say control
goes to radio button
bar or yes check box bar or slider right
that's not going to be in 13 0 but
something we want to do
all right
so when i was thinking about these
question things i mean one question i
had was
will it make sense to have them
accessible in manipulate
or in form
is that does that even make any sense
and if it does then we need to have the
net the communication happening via some
dynamic variable somewhere
well okay so what would it look like i
mean right now
this is a pull from the outside object
like setting right rather than a
dynamic variable thing
boy okay
um okay so the issue is
in an interface how do you
okay so there are two possibilities
either you know it's state because it's
setting a dynamic variable or you pull
it state out
right those are the two cases
now for example this thing here
is a less than magnificent pulling the
state out
right as in what one could imagine is
something built from ordinary controls
where one wants to essentially harvest
the state
so make something go ahead we we have we
have a construct dynamic setting which i
don't know if you recall
but it is the thing that wraps an
invisible setting around an expression
so that if that expression were used as
input it would do the harvesting
automatically
okay so if you take your n9 for instance
and wrap it in dynamic setting of panel
of that
that produces an output which when
interpreted as input
does the setting thing
no no no no evaluating place
i mean so so here we have an output now
evaluating that output does the setting
so it doesn't evaluate to something with
head radio button bar it evaluates to
um beeped
oh no there we go green right
i don't know if this is
well relevant
i don't know either
um
okay let's come back again it's an
example of automatic harvesting i guess
yes
well which this is not doing this is not
doing automatic harvesting this is doing
sit there and just
uh kind of
idle
until a harvester comes in and harvests
you
right that's what that's doing that's
not self-harvesting in any way
am i wrong guys
right that's that's right
okay right we could say we could
certainly hook up setting to work on
question object
okay
i think that makes sense
on question object
so i see so question that would extract
whatever the
the thing was if you're using it out of
a form notebook okay but in a manipulate
the way that you communicate
the value of a variable
i mean sorry the the way that you
communicate a dynamic thing is through
the value of a variable and that's the
only mechanism we have for doing that
so here the question would be
if this is the control
yeah i mean so this this would be the
analog this question object thing will
be the analog of a control in a
manipulate would it not
right because the manipulate when it's
eventually doing its thing like let's
say i say manipulate
um and then i've got to have a payload
here
let's say i say
you know list xxx
comma x comma
list
red green blue
right
[Music]
okay so now
it will do this
so what makes sense here
is it's this thing here this
this
kind of destination for x
that's where we will put the question
object
is that not correct
just like i could say in there i could
say here if i'm not mistaken i could say
slider
there is that right
no what the heck did that do
how do i make
i think you want that to be a function
so slider of hash
why do i need hash well hash for the
first hash one is dynamic of x and hash
two is the difference if i just do this
well then you'll get a slider who's that
doesn't have a dynamic binding
no not not hash comma hash
oh hash hash
slot sequence yeah
it doesn't say
it did work but it doesn't have the
right initial value
it doesn't have any initial value so it
guessed
i see
so why is this different from just
saying slider
is that just some kind of um it's not
it's syntactic sugar that lets you do
arbitrary i mean the benefit in the in
the function notation is not to summon
built-in controls but to build your own
controls right
okay we have a convenience syntax we
have control type that can be set as an
option if you want to change so let's go
look at this in more i mean just for
people on the live stream are asking why
is this useful and intuitive it's
beautiful it's magnificent
but
it's not for this purpose so to speak i
mean this is very intuitive this is very
nice
because um
but the issue is what if we okay so
let's understand what what if we wanted
to pick
what if we wanted to use
this question interface thing
a question object wraps assessment
functions around which is irrelevant
right
what if we just want to use a question
interface
as the way
to set values for a
that's basically what we have in mind
here correct
that's yeah that's sounds like what you
have in mind right so i mean
syntactically we could imagine
manipulate taking an association and
that's in that argument position
lou
that would be unambiguous since we don't
support associations there yet
right but i mean so so in other words
then what we would be doing is
taking whatever a question object could
do
whatever a question interface does and a
question interface
returns
something i mean a question interface
has a value correct
what does the unset question interface
do
nothing right now well so this one here
so if i were to say what's the question
object
okay no i know i i i mean even the
question object thing if i had how do i
even get back to the the initial state
and actually peter on the live stream is
commenting that
that it's a bad idea to have
a radio button which is a kind of a
one-way street where how do i get back
to the initial state here
hello i i don't know i don't think you
can how do you instruct your right can
you do that radio button bar of course
you can because the video button how do
you do it radio button don't think you
have a radio button bar in the middle of
your notebook right now i know that but
think about it i've done that is no
because because i had to give what if
you made that something that's not one
of the values make it make it x
then select one how do you get back
you can't
right yeah okay
the same way you can't slide a slider to
a number that's not in the range
yeah all right fair enough
okay
[Music]
um
okay and if we if we thought that was an
important feature one of the things that
having question object question
interface allows for us to do is to have
like a clear button somewhere
in the in the panel
yeah but look if you're doing a higher
level construct or your your i mean okay
if there is no none of the above
for some survey then there is no none of
the above you've got to pick right uh
if there isn't under the above
presumably yeah yeah
right
yep
um
[Music]
kotov on a live stream is saying you
could always unclick you could click a
second time on this that's not how our
interface currently works
it could be but it's not i mean you
could certainly imagine like a thing
where you're clicking points in a 2d
array and you want to clear them all and
you know get back to some right i think
it's a separate thing that's the thing
for lou
for the way that radio button bar works
yeah and locator pane allows removing
thumbs with you know modifier clicks so
maybe right yeah modifier click will be
a reasonable way to start here right but
you can imagine maybe there's an initial
state where there's some data in there
and you want to get back to it yeah
yeah reset reset there would be times
where reset is a useful thing
okay all right so let's go back to the
the what we're talking about here so to
me then
we are not
this is
i mean it bothers me somewhat
that we have two mechanisms here
that basically end up with the same user
interface
one based on dynamic variables
and
you know
one based on harvesting
and
what would it look like if you wanted to
harvest from this
you would say dynamic
of what would you do here would it make
it better if we got rid of the one
argument form of question object and
required assessment
no we don't want to do that
that what would you do if i wanted to
make a dynamic thing
that
was this but where these things set a
dynamic variable how would i do that a
radio button bar
no i'm not asking that i'm asking within
question interface how would i do that
you wouldn't
no that's the wrong answer let's imagine
that i'm using all kinds of fancy
features of question interface not
supported by other control types but yet
i want to provide this dynamic mechanism
for those fancy features that are
supported by question interface and not
lou hasn't developed you know the
geolocator something or other thing as a
generic control but we do have it in
question interface i'm asking how do i
make a dynamic we should not create a
question interface with a fancy
control without creating the control
independently okay i think that's
nonsense i mean look this is i mean what
is
you know
okay so you're saying a drag and drop
interface the sort interface here you're
saying that we'd have to create a
control for every one of these okay if
we're going to have it right we have to
contribute to create the control anyway
we have to do the hard part we might as
well
no we don't have to do the hard part
because the control this is a pretty
special purpose version of that control
okay you're signing lou up for endless
work or lou in general the front-end
team in general for endless work where
we're saying somebody needs some weird
you know thing for
doing i don't know
you know crystallography where they have
some weird kind of control where they're
you know having people put dots of
miller indices or something on some
weird projection of something or other
and then you say oh that should be a
general control but we might want to
introduce that in our essentially
question interface type repository
without it being a general kind of
control okay so what i'm then asking is
if we do that which i think we will want
to do
if we do that and some of those controls
will make no sense
generically as dynamic controls
like these things that are picking you
know a radio button these are i mean i
guess you can use them as dynamic
controls but they are much more useful
as harvested things
so i'm asking what is the bridge between
question interface and dynamic
okay lou how do you set
when you say dynamic
uh
how do you say
that the x
is a dynamic variable set to the value
of this thing
do you understand what i'm asking it's
very basic so
every control
as it's i know i'm not talking about
controls i'm saying you have this thing
and i'm going to make a change here this
is the thing which exposes itself as a
user interface
okay
but it is not
a known pre-programmed control
do you see what i'm saying so you want
to bind some some you want to bind this
to a dynamic variable something that's
correct
so and your question is what the
language design for that is what is that
do we already have that capability i
mean and i was going to mention that in
con for controls the language design is
that the dynamic of a variable is you
know the first article
right right but it isn't in this case so
let's say what i mean what if inside the
association we had control goes to
uh you know slider dynamic of x
yeah
you know what's doing no no inside the
question interface specifically no
no that's not solving the right problem
the problem that i'm asking for
is assume
that just like in this case here where i
have setting of this thing so presumably
this question object if i were to do
this okay let's imagine that i have
something like this
i have this and then i uh evaluate in
place and i get this okay i think we all
agree that this could harvest in place
right right
okay let's say instead
that i want this instead of harvesting
in place i want this to set a dynamic
variable
how would i do that
isn't there a way with dynamic or
dynamic module couldn't i just set this
as initial as some kind of value in a
dynamic module
well implemented surely that's how it's
implemented yeah i mean all you need to
do is mention what global so so there's
already a binding to some local variable
you want to bind it to some variable in
the user space i think that variable has
to be mentioned
somewhere in the input possibly as a new
element of this association no but but
why why isn't there a thing that just
says something like this you know
dynamic bind
you know x comma control
just like your dynamic setting
just becomes
a
well dynamic settings i mean it's the
same
time thing it's the same story if you
had a zero like the zero argument slider
that thing comes out there's no dynamic
variable bound to it from the user's
point of view
yes so how would you make it after the
fact make a dynamic variable that's
bound right that's what i'm asking right
what is the external wrapping for
sliding i assume dynamics at setting at
slider does not work right
it's supposed to explain you you can't
artificially so if you have slider of no
arguments
there's nothing in that output that can
advertise
anything to any variable this is a pure
front-end thing it does not communicate
with the kernel at all
i understand that so i'm asking how do i
find this you can't artificially bind
this output to some other dynamic
variable if that's not what you're
asking all right then that's what i'm
asking that's what i'm asking why can't
i do that why is there no mechanism to
do that
because there there is this is a pure
front-end object there's no kernel
involved in this so the point is that
the event that is generated as i move
this the front end knows it changed
but it doesn't okay as it is configured
here it makes no
uh you know it does not broadcast
anything to the kernel to say there was
a change right whereas if that had been
slider of x the dynamic of x
then that knows to broadcast to the
kernel that there is a change is that
correct right absolutely okay so what
i'm saying is there's no reason why you
can't put an outer wrapper here
that says
this thing
is going to be a broadcast to the kernel
thing
which
so the issue that you're bringing up is
if i make this thing
i i simply don't understand why this
can't transform itself to something
which has the same broadcast to the
kernel feature that slider of dynamic
effects i guess it depends on at what
point are you
if you want to do this you know
in a separate output sometime in the
future i can't quite picture how that
would be doable okay if you're talking
about doing it directly in an input so
dynamic bind of x comma slider
could evaluate to or even just typeset
to
slider of dynamic of x
that makes sense so you you're not going
to be able to use the first argument of
slider to do this okay that's the whole
point you're going to be given a control
that is settable in the front end just
as these ones are
okay
however this one is settable in the
front end but it does not pre-contain
the broadcast information
now possibly the internal code of this
could be made to
have something which is a hidden
broadcasting that could be picked up on
by a dynamic bind function on the
outside
to understand what i'm saying is an
efficiency hack because it isn't you
know in principle conceptually you could
be doing polling harvesting of this
thing
do you get what i'm saying
i think i do
right conceptually dynamic bind could
simply say
you know check every millisecond what's
the state of that control if it's
changed then go broadcast something to
the current
now that's obviously not what we want
implementationally but that's the
conceptual thing
and that would allow us to unify
something which is this question
interface thing
with
you know the current dynamic mechanism
right and similarly
so so
in this syntax that you've that you're
proposing
there's an
implicit you know this control is
somehow broadcasting a single value
good point how does how does well how
does that work okay so good question
in question interface a single value
well even if it's even if that value
happens to be like an array or something
structure
uh is implied
okay so question interface is a single
result object right it's the same value
that would be passed to the assessment
function
that's what you're getting
right so okay so that control
has the feature that okay so here's the
here's the syntactic flow so to speak
semantic flow
setting of that control returns
something
dynamic bind bad name
of x comma that control
will
dynamically
assign the setting of control to x every
time it needs to be assigned
does that make sense lou
i understand what you mean yes
all right does dynamic bind return a
version of it where's the exact same
thing as dynamic does it's the same as
slider of dynamic of x
if i wrote dynamic bind here if i wrote
dynamic bind of this of x comma slider
that would be equivalent to
slider of dynamic of x right but that
returns that
right if you put in a slider object it
doesn't modify it in place
you know what i mean
i mean it did i think the output the
typeset output would be radically
different between these two inputs why
why
why
i think it would be identical
all this is doing is in the same obscure
hidden way that this is dynamically
binding access the slider moves so would
this be it's doing it in a different
obscure hidden way no it's not it's the
idea is to be the same this is well
every time the slider moves change the
value of x
right
[Music]
yes
okay that that that other thing is doing
the exact same thing isn't it
it has the same effect yes and why isn't
it typeset the same
because you want to be able to pass
things into dynamic bind that aren't
strictly controls that don't know how to
deal with no no no no no no that's an
implementation issue remember what i
said well that's what i'm saying it's
implemented differently the boxes would
look
now look the the box structure would be
different for these two cases oh yeah
yeah the box structure will be different
that's the appearance on the screen
would be identical yes i agree with that
no problem with that i agree with you
the box structure will be different
and
you know
it could be the case
okay so implementationally it might have
to reach in and grab
some hidden
dynamically set variable
and question interface could
conventionally you know could could do
the transaction of providing such a
thing
making sense
yeah there'd be some contract between
question object and setting
exactly
right but i mean so i'm just trying to
understand i mean this may not be a
thing we implement instantly but i'm
trying to understand what is the
relationship between these two worlds
and it seems like this is the
relationship that this thing
is a way of generating an interface that
just sits there
you know
representing the setting that was given
okay
which could then be harvested using
setting
submitted using its own
submission mechanism where that's
completely different from what happens
with you know slider of dynamic of x
where there is no submission mechanism
it is communicating via these dynamic
variables um can i point out one other
thing so setting
doesn't operate on boxes setting
operates on expressions
so if one of these questions objects is
you know you've picked a color you've
chosen blue
is that choice reflected in
the
expression if you were to coerce that
to an input is the is the choice
serialized into the into the input
or are there plans to do so
okay so let's just try to do an answer
to that well let's just take this and
ask for the input form of that
lawful lawful
yeah but green is there
oh i see question framework private
input green
okay
so if i if i were to reevaluate this
i don't claim that this is ideal i'm
just pointing out that the choice is
there
yeah okay so it does
it does correctly serialize with its
choice
so it is merely for setting it has a
fighting chance of being able to pull
this out
right although we may want to change how
this yeah we may want to give it a
wrapper around here so that's set so
it's safe so it isn't just setting like
going in
you know into the jungle and pulling out
you know a butterfly that happened to
find flapping around that might not have
been the correct butterfly
indeed
um
okay
all right so i think given this
i'm sort of okay with this two-world
mechanism
because
there's a bridge that we can build
between them
okay so that then means that with
question interface we would be
optimizing um
the
um
uh
um
let's see
we'd be um
we'd kind of be optimizing for things
which people want to put in as questions
which is a little different maybe than
what we optimized for controls but we
can always make a control out of this
which doesn't seem crazy this seems okay
i think i'm convinced here so if one
wanted to use a question object and
manipulate one could use this dynamic
bind trick
yes is that the workflow that's the
workflow i mean you would do that under
the hood i think but at least that's the
concept sure
so in other words you would simply put a
question interface right in there you
would say x list x comma question
interface and it would just do the right
thing and manipulate syntax has the
variable and yeah
right okay all right i think we have a
plan there okay let's go back
now to look at the question interface
types
choose multiple
see what the heck is that that's what we
want to review in this meeting that we
have nine minutes left for
i went ahead and had another one set up
for next week
okay we needed to do this discussion
guys the one we just did
um i mean you understand why we need to
do that discussion right because we're
not just going to make up a whole you
know a whole set of things that will
eventually show up and manipulate as
well
yeah i understand
okay so like select so it is the case
for every one of these that there is a
return value
right so select pair
what does that return
i don't even know what that means so
that means that means you have a value
and you've got a set of is this animal
vegetable mineral exactly and it's got
to replay whatever right
it's a weird name hey you figured that
one out though last time it was called
something else and you couldn't figure
it out oh i couldn't figure it out from
the name i could figure it out from the
categorize an item
select pair i absolutely could not
figure out
okay that that to me i don't think it's
a common one anyway but yeah it's right
i mean to me that what that most brings
to mind i was just walking out a couple
of days ago and i saw one of those um
uh people who
deals with the you know one of the some
you know phone repair person who had
opened up a um
you know one of those uh
things that is full of pairs
you must have seen that right
maybe nobody knows what i'm talking
about
twisted pairs of wires oh okay
right it's a whole that's what happens
when i remember years and years ago it's
like 35 years ago i remember
actually in my house in um
in champaign um that uh which was out in
the in the sort of wilds
of countryside i was like i need to get
a faster
you know i was getting some faster
internet connection or something there
before it was even called an internet
connection um and you know how did they
actually do it well the answer was that
there were a bunch of these pairs of you
know these so-called pairs which are
just twisted pairs of wire and there
were like you know 64 of them that all
sort of arrived at some poll
near
you know near the house and
basically somebody came out and they
tested each pair
and they figured out which one
would be was
you know had the right insulation on it
somewhere down the line to be able to
transmit data at 64 kilobits per second
or something instead of 16 kilobits per
second so it was purely a question of
let's hope that one of these 64 wires is
good enough so that's what select pair
makes me think of i don't think most
users are going to run into that well
let's because that too that's too young
height of industry
um
okay so
but seriously what we need to do here
okay so
i think about shopping for socks
oh that's a good one
yeah neither none of these are what we
actually i mean
uh
you know what is the type of thing that
we're calling it so radio button bar is
very much this is what this is not what
it does this is what it looks like right
right
so in a sense we have a different name
space here which is what it does as
opposed to what it looks like
right what you're asking the student to
do
right and or the survey fella or
whatever
okay
so i i like that distinction i mean that
means that
that
you know something okay so let's
understand what the
choose
multiple how what the heck is choose
multiple versus multiple choice that's
checkbox
i know
i know but it's obviously horrifying
okay so let's just understand
there are certain question types where
there's a name for the question type
multiple choice would actually be
known as
choose one exactly but it's such a
commonplace term we just want to nail it
on the head right
yeah well maybe we have an alternative
there
um yeah that's fine we can implement it
both ways but i mean in in
okay so
cholo on the livestream is suggesting
select category and i agree that will be
a much better name than select power is
that what it was last week
that's what it was
you were vehement stephen not to call it
that
well i think we hadn't understood what
the okay it's because it's because the
example we gave you the categories
didn't really make sense as categories i
don't remember what the it was like
select the vice president accompanying
the president or something right oh okay
so that's a hopeless thing right right
so that yeah they weren't really
categories but mapping perhaps it was it
was okay so that's the wrong thing so i
see so select category is then wrong
so categorize an item isn't right
this is
select what goes with what
right goes with it's like matching
right yes that's right matching would be
a good word right i think we avoided
match because there are some of these
where it might be pattern based
well exact thing okay we need a language
so to speak a
okay so what we're describing here is
what it is that you want okay so here's
here's how we should think about this
think about the prompting text
okay for a survey which says choose one
of the following
okay that would be what you're calling
multiple choice
you know select any that apply
right
you know so we have to think about what
is the
text that goes along with so in this
case of categorize an item it's
find you know find the match
find matches or something i don't know
what the right exact term is but i think
that's kind of where we go
so all of these would have to be i mean
like
text completion what the heck is that
type set to fill in a lot of black or
blank
yep that's okay
okay yeah
um
so
again that's a noun text completion what
we might be saying is that what this
should be is a verb
right so question interface choose one
here
versus choose any
for select any that apply perhaps
so in other words we could use a um
uh
um
you know in other words is this a verb
and does that work for everything okay
how about a numeric range
so i think yeah
i think verbs is the way to go
okay let's check these though and
sometimes okay so draw
okay so draw what would that be
would that just be draw yeah
yeah okay so let's go down these for a
second okay click location
yeah all right and that's a that's a
verb already
um
so that first one we choose any
because it isn't necessarily multiple
right
um
let's see list multiple enter multiple
answer into input fields
it's like a repeating element input
field i understand
well so what's the thing for a generic
for just an input field we called it
short answer but that's not a verb oh
um
[Music]
well maybe enter text
that's your text and and then we've also
got in fact ethan on live stream
comments on code we could have enter
code
right
right and yeah that's that's definitely
these are more intuitive one that we're
going to have from the beginning even
that's not on the list i think
we've hooked up the code equivalent
content all right
[Music]
um
so we could take another pass with this
direction right but let's keep going
here i mean sort for example
uh it's okay
yeah it's okay
um determine whether a question is true
or false
so that will be two
that will be a box
that will simply be a
that's a um just a check box yep
no but we want a verb
what would you say
verify
no no no what you would say is you would
simply ask the question
is the moon made of green cheese
question mark check box
um
is true
it's not a verb
yeah okay
determine truth
certified
um
confirm
no none of those are the right meaning
i'm in the right sense what about check
how about check
no but it's kind of funny because it's a
check box you are so energized
i thought it was kind of clever on two
two ways because it's a check box and my
question is how many function names do
we have that are puns
and the answer is we have a few
and i'm not sure how well they work out
in other words where
um
yeah yeah i mean block is the most
famous pun
which i didn't even notice for years
block is both the thing
that
is a block of code and a thing that
blocks the value of a variable
well which one were you thinking of when
you first put it in block of code okay
um
[Music]
okay so
let's see
[Music]
um answer true false answer
answer
pick true false
or just pick true
right because you're not [ __ ] the
false ones you're just picking the true
ones
picture isn't terrible it's not great
um
[Music]
jolo asks on live stream the second
choice in select pair which is not which
would be something like um
match
match items or something match
is it match items
is this for which one select pair
yeah match item
right you you only do one
it's like two
uh action menus left and right and then
you're matching one item from the left
to one item on the right
right the one that we call pair right
now is the one where it's multiple
i see
i mean it's almost like find matching
item
or fine matching items
yeah
okay in any case these need to be verbs
okay so the question the remaining thing
before we wrap here is
um you had
provided a candidate documentation
thing
right so this is the type of content
that will go on the pages that each one
of those interface types will have its
own page and this is the type of content
that we'll put there
so
if you think there's anything blatantly
missing from this let us know but i
think the thing we wanted to try and
make a template yeah right i think that
the most obvious thing to do here which
would show up on guide pages as well
is at the top
i mean it's got to be very very obvious
what the thing roughly looks like
you see what i'm saying yes
and
possibly you just look down to the first
example
but possibly we actually want
see the problem with giving something at
the top
is that you have to actually pick
content for it
and that's going to be difficult so the
only way we would put something at the
top is if it was a stylized graphic
design thing where instead of red green
blue it would be just you know gray bars
for those things
am i making sense
just to give some indication of what the
heck the thing is
yeah i understand and i think that that
will be useful
for you know to have for a guide page
you know the gray bar versions of each
of those we want to be able to add these
things without getting
that design element optionally though
right and have it come in later that's
fine but it may be that there's an easy
enough way to do it that we simply take
every every um piece of text
and replace it with some gray bar but
that may be all we're doing
okay
and then otherwise it's just whatever
this thing comes out as
um the items on the agenda did you
already look at those
um the
on on the right side the right notebook
it'll be harder when you're like
clicking on a map what's the abstraction
of a map look like you know
the label uri
these items cvs folder label uri
yes
that's fine
yes those are fine
already
um
what the heck is this thing
we talked about this a couple weeks ago
it's for like question pools or adaptive
quizzes
where it generates a question when it's
triggered
based on a function oh right
and i do like the idea of of seeing what
we can get from the problem generator
which had a pretty elaborate ui
and how do challenges relate to this so
they they they're just
they're simpler they just uh i mean the
good thing about challenges is that
rick's code equivalence is something
that we can reuse here
yes which is a big deal we've hooked up
as a prototype which is really going to
be what a lot of people want
right
i mean we'll need as we know we'll need
math equivalents as well which we have
in the problem generator
you know we have
you know is is
you know what i'm saying 3x is the same
as
whatever
yes and and we know we need multiple
levels of that because there's a level
of math at which 3x is the same as x
plus x plus x and there's a level where
it isn't
as we've talked about
the guy to talk to absolutely not
people the people in um uh
he would be for very different kinds of
questions no so that's that's wolf
enough for math content people
okay brad like that
we already talked okay
all right yeah for problem generator
yeah yeah
okay
ethan is commenting among the things we
should have is annotate image and state
audio annotate video
it's a good point
so yeah i've got it okay
because i mean i suspect he's thinking
about machine learning applications
where
essentially okay so let's just talk
about that use case for one second right
i mean there's also the normal form
notebook that doesn't have question
objects
right if you're not a doing assessment
that's usually the way to go
yeah thank you for doing this thing with
making setting work and stuff and being
able to use it like that then
you would be doing it in four notebooks
if you're trying to like label data and
stuff like that well let's just
understand that workflow for a second
okay
so
you generate a
you say you know you're going to send it
out
to a bunch of curators
you've got lots of pictures and you're
going to say
where are the tigers in these pictures
or something
what's the workflow for that and then
you want to collect back the results of
their curation
right you can use a normal form notebook
and the the action of submission would
be add to a data pin and you send it out
and then you watch your data bin fill
out okay so what is the thing that
allows you to annotate the tigers
yeah
yeah a form object or whatever in in the
form notebook us uh
we don't have that control i mean the
what's input fields right you just
put the image the image would be in the
notebook and you'd have an input field
right no no no
no what you've just described is the
third leg
of this you know basically what you're
saying is
this is another thing the case of a form
object
is another case where you can have an
interface element
right so just like just like dynamic is
one of these cases where you should be
able to use a question interface
so i suspect a form should be able to
take a question interface
do you see what i'm saying just like we
can say so that's another thing we have
to think through so just like a form
can take a
control world thing a dynamic control
so it should also be able to take a
question interface right we thought
about that at the beginning of this
that's okay fine so then in that case i
just want to make sure we understand
that to me is is how that would work
right
of how the um
uh
you know the labeling data in a notebook
would work
right
let's check that we can do that use case
okay with form notebooks and with this
question interface mechanism because for
example the thing about pick and pick a
place on a map or
what ethan is commenting on we should
have a built-in question interface that
says annotate image where you can either
pick a point the tiger is there put your
point on the on the nose you know pin
the tail on the donkey
whatever it is is that an american is
that is that yes yeah
okay you know i never know with things
like that which kind of go back to
uh i don't think my kids were ever into
the pin i wouldn't have known if it was
english yeah
right the
um
anyway so you know one thing is you know
pin the tail on a donkey at one point
and another is sort of uh
give the bounding box of the donkey
right
okay so both of those controls are of
interest
and and conceivably even
annotate the picture with what kind of
animal is in it give its bounding box
and give its name
i mean those are all perfectly
reasonable i mean not so much
uh
well could perfectly well be i mean
honestly that's the type of thing i
could imagine in some quiz
actually i would imagine that's a
perfectly good elementary school
activity there's a picture of a you know
zoo animals multiple zoo animals
annotate the animals but nobody would
give that as a question right now
because they do not have the technology
to deal with it
if you understand what i'm saying
but we do
do do you get what i'm saying yeah we
just need to make the interviews for it
right
right so so that's an argument for
having richer interfaces like that
and i need to make sure that they work
in all the environments we want them to
work in
exactly
um
okay there's a question about simplify
drawing to put a circle square over each
tiger i think that gets into i mean that
is an interesting that that's an
interesting question
that one would be more like draw but
have a background image
which is a reasonable thing oh yeah it
certainly would be in uh one of the
options to draw background has been in
the specs for as an option for a bunch
of these things
okay
well maybe then that's the way that you
do the annotation of the tiger or the
donkey or whatever it is is you just put
it as a background and then you're using
the drawing mechanism
right
okay there's a comment from btc here
semantic labels on individual pixels
yeah i mean so that's a that's another
thing
is well that's another complicated issue
here is you have sort of a paintbrush
that is painting semantics onto pixels
that is you paint over the donkey and
every thing where your donkey paintbrush
touches that pixel it makes that pixel a
donkey pixel
if that makes sense
i understand what you're saying yes
you lost me but i wrote it down
donkey pixels right that's it
the takeaway from the meeting today is
doxypixels draw donkey pixels
can i clarify something um
all right so so this whole concept of
making sure that all of our interfaces
work and all the environments we want
them to work in so we have pin the tail
on the donkey
control type
uh pin the tail on the donkey should
work in
question objects we want them to work in
regular form notebooks regular form
notebooks use form objects so if we want
them to work in form objects do we want
pin on the tail and the donkey to also
work in web forms
yes okay so then my question is doesn't
that go back to bob's earlier point that
pin the tail on the donkey has to be
implemented as a generic control type
which you said no not supposed to do
because it no
no no because
whatever however question interface is
implemented right whatever it turns into
in terms of boxes
that is what your responsibility is to
turn it into boxes the front end team's
responsibility is to render those boxes
right so in other words you're what
we're doing is we're running you know
they've already implemented so you might
implement it using a text field or using
a slider or something like that they've
already implemented the way that that
renders and the cloud team has already
implemented how that renders in the
cloud
am i making sense
well web forms isn't in the cloud it's
issues i know i know i know that's a
painful piece
and that's not clear how that would work
and maybe the way maybe the way that
works is that those forms that use these
fancier pin the tail type controls have
to be an embedded notebook
okay
i think that's the right way to do it
because otherwise i think that's a you
know an infinite rabbit hole otherwise
donkey hole whatever it is
um
the uh
but in terms of getting clarity bob did
that i mean and schroeder does that make
sense to you what stephen just said
i'm
right i mean we're to have things that
work in form objects and notebooks and
right and then
we work in a cloud deployed form
making them work in a
cloud-to-platformers can take a lot of
work for somebody that's not in this
meeting sure but not not necessarily
it'll work it may just be the embedder
it may just be you you have that
fragment no notebook fragment the only
question is how does the notebook
fragment communicate its output to the
enclosing html i mean and bob's point is
just that we don't own web forms and and
i will make sure that that gets right
but i think jan
well it's it's w
oh but yeah it could handle it yeah
yarns and better i believe can return
things because that's very similar to
embedded html
and embedded service and so on which i
believe can't have a mechanism for
returning things
so i believe that has been solved
okay and we should we should leverage
that mechanism
okay
okay
good stuff um
uh and and yeah right and the third
right so it's
it's forms
dynamic controls
and harvestable question interfaces are
the three places and each one has its
own slightly different way of specifying
interface i mean honestly this is not
horrifying it just we need to separate
these it's just like you know functional
programming versus procedural
programming versus whatever else you can
do it in different ways depending on how
you're thinking about what you're doing
and so in this case
you know what we need to emphasize here
is the now is the verb form of what you
are trying to you know what the prompt
would be
as opposed to the dynamic
interfaces which is emphasizing what it
looks like
as opposed to forms
form objects which are emphasizing what
they're emphasizing the data that is
coming in right
those are the three cases right
question interface is emphasizing the
prompt
dynamic controls is emphasizing what it
looks like
and forms is emphasizing what data comes
in from
it yes
okay
so and i think using that that
clarification is probably useful on
guide pages and things
to to make people understand what these
different approaches to interfaces are
even though they interoperate
okay
i'll make sure to share that with brian
van verlou and everyone too
okay
thanks very much guys thanks to folks on
the live stream too